i'm gonna show you some magic
it's the real thing
i mean uh
it's all the real
marvel is so overrated
hello and welcome to some sub a channel
about how to survive in the online
jungle
my name is bradley and today we're going
to talk about realistic deep fakes
like the recent one with tom cruise
what's up tick-tock
what threats they pose and how average
users should adapt to this new reality i
need your clothes
your boots and your motorcycle whether
what we see
and hear is always as it seems
president trump is a total and complete
[ __ ] i
will lose my mind
it's the real thing
so tom cruise's account was recently
created
now tom shared a video where he eats a
lollipop plays golf and
does coin tricks but this account has
actually been deep fake
and it's actually the most realistic
example to date
tom cruise's tiktok has actually been
talked about by the world's largest
media
because in just a couple of days the
video got millions of views and almost
700 000 people subscribed to the account
so understandably people in the comments
are utterly confused
but this is something that's quite
predictable i mean people usually expect
deep fakes to look something like this
[Music]
by looking at these kinds of pictures
you can easily identify when something's
been deep faked
however this is the real crux of the
problem people
are not the only ones that are being
tricked so users actually checked tom
cruise's deep fakes
using an ai powered deep fake detection
service and
voila the deep fakes passed the check
but look
let's imagine if the fake tom cruise
announced on his tick tock that he was
collecting money for a new film
or maybe he urged his fans to storm the
capital
of the white house do you actually
remember when scammers hacked the
verified and official accounts of bill
gates and elon musk
i think it was on twitter they posted
tweets asking to send bitcoins to
certain wallet
they then promised to double the sum
right now
these tweets were quickly deleted
obviously but before that
users had actually transferred 50 000 to
the scammers what's more
we are subconsciously afraid of identity
theft i'm not talking about just
stolen passwords or personal account
numbers maybe personal
photos and videos a stretch i'm actually
talking about a technology that can on
my behalf
say or do things that i would have never
done or said
why are politicians in all of washington
so concerned about
deep faith deep fakes can put words
in people's mouths you know make people
say things like vagina
and poop now people tried to use deep
fakes for political frame-ups right off
the bat
nancy pelosi's speech for example was
manipulated to make her look intoxicated
and we thought we had some level of
agreement but you never know
but this president of the united states
so that's what happened this morning
and we thought we had some level of
agreement
but you never know with this president
of the united states so that's what
happened this morning
it's absolutely no surprise that the
former us president donald trump tweeted
about the video
and the message then swept through all
social networks
we're most afraid that deep fakes can be
used in this way
[Music]
but it's important to remember that deep
fakes can actually be used ethically in
the modern world
for example to improve image resolution
of old or low quality videos right you
don't need the classic upscale anymore
the network redraws the image look at
how the quality has changed
deep fix can synchronize lips and speech
right and this process is called
lip sync you might have heard that
before now
it's worth noting that adjusting lip
movements to any linguistic
articulation would actually be a real
breakthrough in terms of film and tv
dubbing
let's see how this actually works in a
psa that was aimed at combating malaria
with david beckham now here
he speaks nine languages watch the lips
[Music]
possibility
[Music]
now let's take a look at another example
here these are shots from rogue one
the star wars story now the face on the
left of the video was edited by
professional team
and cgi equipment both of which are kind
of expensive by the way
now this process only took 24 hours
using
an 800 pc i think around 500 images of
carrie fisher from the original star
wars movies
not the results not foodless but still
pretty impressive right
so here's a later version sure you'll
agree the result looks
much more real help
in the future deep fake technology could
save the film industry a lot of time and
money
the self-learning algorithm powering
deep fakes was invented back in 2014 by
in goodfellow then stanford student the
technology has traditionally only been
used among ai researchers
and developers the algorithm is called
gan which stands for generative
adversarial network now two neural
networks compete with each other like an
art forger and the gallerist
the former forges paintings and the
latter identifies the forged artwork
now the forger is the generative neural
network the gallerist however is the
discriminative network
imagine that a forger for instance tries
to paint mona lisa for the first time
and instead ends up with a lot of
digital noise within the image
now the gallerist has seen the painting
a million times
he knows every detail and can easily
identify fake
so the discriminative network learns by
comparing
real images so it can detect things such
as digital noise within
an image for example now the generative
network will adjust to the
discriminative
and paint until the gallerist improves
the forward painting
so that's actually until it becomes
indistinguishable from the original
despite being anything other than the
original right
now if the forger wants to paint better
it needs to hone its skills
same for the gallerist right the longer
the networks interact with each other
the better results they have i actually
came up with an idea to make a deep fake
can i do that is it easy how much will
it cost will it be realistic
well deep fakes with tom cruise were
made by a belgian
visual effects expert i think his name
is christopher um
now he's one of the most skilled deep
fake creators in the world
there's an interesting quote here he
said i'd like to show
people the technical possibilities of
these things i don't intend to use it in
any way where i would upset people
i just want to show them what's possible
in a few years so
here's what you need to do number one
find someone who looks like tom cruise
check
tom cruise's impersonator miles fisher
is zoom's good friend
so that works fisher perfectly imitates
cruiser's facial expressions here his
movements and his articulations
secondly it's time to use the machine to
be precise you ought to use a neural
network model that's been trained on a
lot of
tom cruise's own films now lastly um
actually manually processed the videos
frame by frame
in adobe after effects and used davinci
resolve for color correction
can i do the same i think it's unlikely
i'm pretty underqualified
right if i tried the result would look
something like
[Music]
well so that's why i looked for help it
took me a couple of hours
and to be honest i checked many
different youtube channels that make
deep fake videos
but i did find one with contact
information so
i got in contact with an anonymous
author who introduced himself as john
he actually asked me tons of questions i
think some of them were
will we change the whole head or just
the face what would the resolution be
and the lighting
which celebrity are we faking i also
want to mention john asked for a photo
of mine
to measure my skull and yeah so this is
actually important for the quality of
the final face
now luckily i didn't need to record any
videos for the neural network to train
why well i actually have my old youtube
channel where john found some videos
that are actually suitable for the
network training
so you started the ball rolling step one
search for material
these can be feature films youtube
videos etc the main thing
is to find as many variants and
varieties of a face with a lot of
emotions facial expressions tilts and
turns of the head etc
step two is to chop this video into
frames so the entire video needs to be
split into frames and this can take a
very long time
after this the neural network
automatically extracts faces
we select the required parameters and
then we launch the neural network
step three is to export the faces of
course the neural network can
sort faces according to different
criteria but at the end
we'll still have to go through
everything and clean our sets of
low quality images and debris for
instance step four is to train an
x-segment
to make a really good fake it's
advisable to mark and train the areas of
both source
and destination faces these are the
so-called masks
step five is to train a model it goes
without saying that the better and more
powerful your equipment is
then the better the faster the deep fake
will turn out
step six is to merge the final stage for
the neural network is to connect the
result we received in the training
process
so that's of the original video and
lastly step seven is post production
we look at the results and then go to
the video editor for final processing
then it all comes down to the skills and
abilities of the producer
so remember we saw an example of the
deep fake at the start of the video
well let's look at that again what do
you think
marvel is so overrated what if i was a
criminal
how many people could i have tricked
well none i think
but would you have believed it let me
know in the comments i'd be quite
interested to know
so in conclusion my data set was made up
of 8000 frames which took
three to four hours to create in terms
of the total time
it took three days and total cost was
around 250
[Music]
protection technologies have luckily
evolved together with these
deep fakes now the university of buffalo
actually develops a tool that
automatically recognizes deep fake
photos
i think it does this by analyzing light
reflections in the eyes
which is quite interesting right when we
look at something the image of it
reflects
in our eyes in real photos reflections
in both eyes
usually have the same shape and color
right
but computers they can't make two
similar reflections
as they combine many photos into one
now other tools analyze digital noise
the structure of natural and computer
generated noise can differ greatly
which also helps us to identify fake on
the topic of protection
let's look at the things that are
actually protecting from right
experts have named the three most
dangerous deep fake methods
so number one is deep fake voice
phishing this is a type of deep fake
technology that can actually
successfully simulate
a voice this is the most profitable
method that scammers use nowadays
actually a good case study for you in
2019 scammers used this
cloned voice technology to extort 243
000 from a british energy company's ceo
that's mad number two fabricated private
remarks
or deep fake videos where public figures
brainwash people and manipulate public
opinion
you guys remember the well-known videos
with barack obama president trump is a
total and complete [ __ ]
finally we need to be aware of synthetic
social botnets
or fake social network accounts modern
neural networks
are great for creating people who
genuinely have never existed
if you go to this person does not
exist.com
you'll see a lot of faces just refresh
the page right
the funny thing is all of these people
don't actually exist they were all
created by ai
and this ai can also generate deep fake
texts that imitate
real posts in social networks these
kinds of fake accounts can look real and
they can actually
get followers imagine a pool of these
accounts used to defame a company or a
product
and as for my own personal advice well
number one
be alert when consuming information
online particularly when the topics that
you're engaging with are especially
divisive or inflammatory
number two seek multiple independent
sources of information
don't assume that an online persona or
individual is legitimate
just based on the existence of video
photographs or audio on their profile
right it might be deep fake and most
importantly
try not to post information about
yourself online that's important
that's it for today anyway see you in
the next video and be safe